nation of macroeconomic policy and
monetary policy we are seeing after a
decade on very very easy in the face
and other shocks
but I think despite those things there
is very clearly in the UK specific
elements
said yesterday
we are monitoring those developments in
financial markets and particular that
British element that British component
very
so how we see
best and indeed a responsibility for
maintaining orderly and well-functioning
markets across a variety of asset
classes
and I can reassure all of you that my
colleagues in the markets and
operational parts of the bank take that
responsibility very very seriously
but let me turn now to my own
responsibilities as a member of the MPC
and as a representative of the monetary
policy side of the bank
hopefully a lot of what I'm going to say
should be self-evident to you but I
think it's an occasion to say it anyway
in the MPC we are certainly not
indifferent to the repricing of
financial assets that we've seen
indeed I would emphasize that
we cannot be indifferent
as a small open market economy
changes in asset prices have an
important influence over macroeconomic
developments through a variety of
channels the cost of financing the cost
of imports and effects on both aggregate
supply and aggregate demand
in taking monetary policy decisions we
need to factor into our assessment of
the outlook for Price developments all
these effects
and include them in our formulation of
policy decisions to reach our two
percent inflation Target
so let me emphasize that is this is the
lens through which the MPC views and
interprets recent Market developments
and I want to reassure you that the MPC
has a very good understanding of its
mandate
to maintain price stability
and of its remits to return inflation to
the two percent Target
now I hope many of you would acknowledge
and it's certainly been my own personal
experience in my last year working at
the bank
that these are quite challenging times
for pursuing that Target
and to be frank
I would acknowledge that recent Market
developments have created their own
additional challenges for the pursuit of
our Target
but despite these challenges
Mai and the NPC's commitment to
achieving two percent Target is
unwavering
foreign
now in the spirit of what we heard from
the vice president
we're broadly speaking use this using
the same framework we're employing
monetary policy to steer aggregate
demand around aggregate supply in a way
that relieves current inflationary
pressures in order to achieve our goal
the relevance of Market developments
comes from how they influence precisely
this process
but they have to be seen in the context
of other important macroeconomic
macroeconomic influences
including the fiscal news that was
announced last week
as well as developments in Energy prices
developments in labor markets and other
spaces that I think the vice president
has mentioned and I'm sure we'll talk
about later
the vehicle for making that necessarily
comprehensive assessment
is the NPC's forecast process which is
embodied in the round that we're now
beginning to start on leading up so the
mpc's decision meeting in early November
now given we also want to hear from
other members of the panel and have a
lively discussion I'll leave elements of
what's really going to enter into that
assessment for the discussion and for
the forecast itself although I do want
to flag clearly at this point that in my
view
the combination of fiscal announcement
we've seen will act as a stimulus to
demand in the economy
now I recognize for many of you in this
room
talking about November seems a long time
away
so I used to work as has been said in
financial markets and you know for those
of you doing algorithmic Trading a long
time can be nanoseconds
and even for those of you who are in the
media or political circles
you're operating a daily cycle or hourly
cycle
but the better way to run monetary
policy is to adopt a more considered
approach a lower frequency approach
recognizing what monetary policy can do
which is very important and which it can
act in a very powerful way to achieve
but also recognize its limitations as a
vehicle for fine-tuning shorter term
developments
now understandably and perhaps
reflecting my experience myself working
financial markets this does beg the
question well what's going to happen in
the meantime
so during that mean time we are relying
on our communication
and events like this of our policy
intentions and framework and the
transmission of those intentions
via expectations and Market developments
if that is to work well
we are relying on the basic
institutional framework for macro policy
and markets being effective and intact
and that in turn
relies on the essential credibility and
stability of the institutional framework
drawing on clearly defined
responsibilities
clearly identified objectives
and respect for Independence
so in that broad context
I personally found the statement we
heard from the treasury yesterday
helpful in making a clear commitment and
announcing a clear timetable to clarify
the new government's fiscal rules and
submit to the independent external
scrutiny of the office for Budget
stability budget responsibility in
developing its new fiscal plans
so let me conclude by asking the
question where does that leave us
and I'm going to sum up with four points
but before I do so let me just say I am
speaking as an individual and I cannot
at this stage speak for the NPC as a
whole
and of course everything I say here
today is conditional on where we stand
as recent events have demonstrated we
can't really know what the future holds
not for the next few weeks not for the
next few days or even perhaps not for
the next few hours
but let me summarize the message
in Four Points
we have all seen recent significant
fiscal news in the past few days
that has had significant Market
consequences
as well as significant implications for
the macro Outlook including but not
exclusively those coming by asset
markets
on the back of all that and in a context
where there is a rebalancing of the
macro policy environment and an
anticipation of looser fiscal policy
I think it's hard not to draw the
conclusion that all this will require a
significant monetary policy response
let me leave it there
[Applause]